it's casey wilson and since it's beauty
week on our show we thought we'd give
her some special pampering in our makeup
room and somebody really gets into doing
her makeup
check this out
hi
okay by the way you look so pretty
already okay i'm happy to be here
i heard that you went to a workout class
and then across the street to the
mcdonald's which i just have to
say i told you
this is why i know how much i love you
okay so 30 women and i did like a month
long you know where you're trying to
commit to like a boot camp and cleansing
was this one of the ones in the book
oh my god i haven't gotten to see you
face to face your book made me the
happiest i've been in so many years
i think it's one of the best books ever
written stop i'm not kidding
i'm not and i'm a reader okay so you
were at the workout class you were doing
computers yeah 30 women we were feeling
so good and it was the end and
everyone's congratulating each other and
in a huddle and a hug and i just slipped
right on out of that hug
and i got in my car and i drove across
the street to mcdonald's i got right
through
the drive-through and i got that vanilla
cone oh it's my favorite yeah it's the
greatest and i maintain you can really
use that as a nice treat so then all the
women are just getting out of the class
and i drive by honking with my cone out
the window did you say i earned it yeah
i was but houston was like flicking them
off it's like what did they do i love
that i would understand they were
astonished
what's happening now
don't be afraid it's the scribble stick
it's like when my kids draw it sort of
looks like when you go to like a plastic
surgeon and they're trying to suggest
some work you came out looking like a
beautiful mind on the wall did you know
that your nose like keeps growing your
whole life that makes a lot of sense
because it's getting it is twice the
size things are getting out of hand with
me and i appreciate your efforts here
so are your friends honest with you
about like your hair makeup wardrobe i
feel like i heard something like they
lack a filter a little bit sometimes
they want more for me in the areas of of
fashion and a girlfriend of mine jessica
st claire who's a wonderful actress and
she was very upset with me and she had
cancer and then she finally got an
amazingly clear scan so we had a party
for her and i showed up late and that
doesn't feel good and i was wearing a a
braid that had been done for me the
night before a very thick braid like a
heidi braid yeah and it had fallen
overnight and she said it made her to
look at that braid made her feel worse
than what you've been going through and
that was hard to hear i said i was not
thinking about what you've been going
through for you to have to look at this
falling out braid on my head and she
said i will accept that but she can't
forget it
and then she said for you to walk in
late we all had to turn and see that
that's hard for her you know
when and why did you start [ __ ] sash
and how did you know that you and your
friend would like you're doing a town
hall you guys
now fill up
forums so my partner daniel schneider
and i i just had my second baby and we
thought let's do a podcast it was six
years ago so we decided to talk about
the real housewives we're just gonna do
six we had so much fun and the audience
is so much fun okay now i want you to
talk like a ventriloquist okay okay so i
love the house eyes and
our audience is so sweet and so forward
effect
again you brought like an inherent
sweetness like you i really do love them
it's not doing it just to make fun of
them all the ideas maybe that's the
difference
oh i don't know if you're going to like
this tone
but if you don't know i changed it just
it was alarming okay so now you can't
talk again okay
tell me it feels like a heartened heart
this tone it might i really do it's more
tomatoey sometimes i feel like i i
really like it see you in more of a
carmine red
but i just loved this i really do like
this
it's really beautiful
now
when you wake up what is your beauty
routine it's so minimal i'm obsessive
about sunscreen so my dermatologist
christy kidd was telling me that
anything you do on your face you know
your any products that you know all the
things you were doing on our faces
that we're going to do all the way down
to the nipple but we're going to do on
the hands but we're also going to do on
the earlobes
did you know that
oh yeah we're doing it on the earlobes
too we can't ignore them
that's what i want to be a public
service announcement
and be an ambassador to that issue we
just got to keep them together that's
all i'm saying and don't sleep in your
earrings because it stretches them down
and they're going to get a little i'm
going to say it they're going to get a
little roast beefy
you don't just tend to them that's all i
know can you tell me a secret about this
shrink next door i like filming it i got
to play paul red's wife which was a
dream
he it's one of my favorite like paul red
pieces i've ever seen i know he's
amazing in it so as well it's it's a
dark comedy but it ended like a true
crime but they're so good in it i am
loving it so
much
it's perfect the four of you like any
day i'm really enjoying it i can't wait
to keep watching it
oh my god okay wow we really how do you
feel i feel good you feel like it's
light it's attractive i feel it's light
and attractive
i love it
i love it
thank you
thank you casey i love you so much the
shrink next door premieres friday
november 12th exclusively on apple tv
plus i cannot recommend it more
[Music]
you